[Music]
hey y'all and here we are yeah
we saw dune
finally yeah
i feel like we're the last the last
people to have seen it well well we
didn't want to go
i mean we didn't really have time though
we didn't really want to go on the
weekend because i thought it would be
too crowded we wouldn't get a good seat
and yeah i i mean i prefer to see movies
in a mostly empty movie theater yeah
yeah dolby theater dead center yeah
right behind me i don't want a bunch of
other [ __ ] in there chewing
popcorn
right behind the damn
uh handicapped seats yeah right to
center so you can put your feet out
[Laughter]
but um
i've been waiting years to see this i'm
a big fan of the original read the book
when i was in high school i read that
book a couple of times when i was in
high school liked it
um i didn't read dune messiah or the
other one so for some reason i just
never got around to other books or you
know other books to read i guess
but um
i wasn't disappointed this [ __ ] movie
was epic man it was breathtaking it was
epic and i've heard
some guys that you know i agree with a
lot you know you usually the guys off at
midnight edge some of our
listeners here you know looking
um like uh khan avatzlon you know and
khan really liked it uh some of the
other guys said that well the acting you
know the lead character the guy who
played paul was kind of wood and other
people there was like some gripes here
and there and i just have to disagree i
liked it i liked i couldn't see anything
wrong with it
um
it's different from the first one
the harkonnens aren't quite as over the
top and [ __ ] you know malevolent
and they're not as prominent they're not
as
prominent
either you never you never see
uh fade in it
um you see rabon and you see the baron
but you don't see fade
they didn't make much out of uh
what was his name
yeah
he's in it
but they never tell you what his name is
and he's not a huge character they don't
even really explain much of what a
mentat is
and um
they show uh what's his name doofer
wasn't that his name duffer the uh uh um
i think that's the name of the atreides
men i think his name was for howard
thinks what his name was he's in it i
don't they do say his name
but um
his role isn't very great it mostly
focuses on paul
which there's nothing wrong with it it's
just a different way of telling the
story
it seemed like i said it seemed a lot
more focused to me and i mean it's been
way longer for me it's like i don't
think i've read the book since i was a
kid or you know since i was like a
teenager um but i remember the story
just through watching the david lynch
ones like you because you are really
into like the dune video games and stuff
like that so i'm pretty familiar with
the overall story um
but i like that i mean denis villeneuve
the dude that directed this i mean he's
been one he's he did a rival obviously
and he did blade runner 2049. he's been
wanting to do this since he was a
teenager he's like it's always been my
dream to like adapt dune because nobody
else had done it all that well and it
was like one of his favorite books when
he was growing up
and i think that it was absolutely the
right decision
to
focus more on
paula tradies and his arc and stuff like
that and all this other stuff is going
on
but
i think it was good that they just sort
of like concentrated on that and then
had the other stuff going on but it
wasn't it wasn't as prominent yeah it
didn't seem as because i kind of feel
like uh the david lynch version and i
hate to call it that because i know
david lynch like it didn't come out the
way he wanted no um there's a bunch of
edits of that so yeah so but i do feel
like that one was a little like
scattered it was kind of like all over
the place and you never really got a
sense of how do all these things relate
to one another and i never had that
problem with this one it's weird because
the david lynch one like i said against
his witch wishes had a lot of that kind
of narration and exposition and stuff
like that and and yet still it was way
harder to follow this one had almost no
exposition and almost no and no
you know voiceovers or anything like
that and it was way easier to follow
interestingly i like i like the original
also and i like some of the ed edits
like
there's a custom edit out there i think
it was called sandwriter or
worm writer edit
that i saw and it was a mixture mixture
of
the the the regular television release
the um
the television release is real long
there's a television release a bunch of
discarded [ __ ] that ended up on some
special editions
and the theatrical release all woven
together into a pretty damn good
narrative and even had like the i think
he had the epilogue that was originally
in the
in the uh what do you call it
in the television release is in it
it's just um
when you talk about the original
the theatrical release was very
it was good it was just that it was kind
of like watching a movie about the old
testament
you're covering a lot of ground in the
singles imagine you're covering moses
and you're covering you know the exodus
and you're covering [ __ ] you know
and also
and you're covering because these are
huge stories you can't really
encapsulate it in one movie and also
it's much like the old testament it's
kind of like stories that were written
by different people over like
drastically different time periods and
don't necessarily
have a through line or have that much to
do with one another
right
and
the dune
series has a religious tone to it
religion plays a big part in the book
and um reading the books it kind of
feels religious in a way
because it's supposed to it was written
by a dude who was a what is the [ __ ]
sociologist or a biologist i forgot what
he was
what was he
i think he was
[ __ ] some kind of
is it was a cultural anthropologist is
that anybody i don't i don't know frank
hubert was he was into a bunch of
science so when when he wrote these
books it was kind of like kind of like
he's talking about artifacts from
another civilization you know so it had
a the dune book had a sense of
authenticity to it
there's something about the original
movie kind of had that weird
authenticity to it also like like
watching
a movie about moses or some [ __ ]
yeah it's like that you know when i say
religion jenny comes around kind of i
don't know if she understands what i'm
talking about no i don't know okay
because i'm not talking about
necessarily like jesus and [ __ ] it's not
what it's like it's just it's almost
like something out of the old testament
like yeah mythology that supposedly
happened and that's kind of the way this
stuff always kind of felt to me
something that supposedly happened a
long time ago even though they're
talking about 20 years in the future 20
000 years in the future yeah that's what
they're talking about
and sometimes they're kind of talking
about it like in the past too at the
same time which is pretty weird
talking about things that haven't
happened yet like it was a long time ago
but um the move i think this movie does
hold up it's
i think it's i mean i really like to
blade runner too i'm gonna call [ __ ]
2049 is what it's called right yeah i
don't remember numbers that well well i
remember one and two real well and three
okay but 2049 sometimes i'll forget that
number
uh so i just call it blade runner two
[ __ ] them you know i'm like that
i think it's
i liked uh blade runner too
this might be bet i think this is better
than blade runner two pretty sure it is
even though i like them both
yeah it's hard to say they're both
really awesome they're both had a very
authentic feel to to them some people
i've talked to some people that didn't
like 20 40 49
and they said well it is so different
than the original i don't like to hear
and when
some of the some of the some of the
reasons why they didn't like that one
kind of made me think that they didn't
really know the story of blade runner
too well that they didn't know what the
original story was
because the story we got from ridley
scott the theatrical release is all
[ __ ] up it's it mis it's missing a lot
of what was supposed to be in there
and a lot of what was cut out a lot of
those ideas were used in 2049
because there's a lot more going on than
met met the eye and yes sucking deckard
was a was a replicate that was the whole
meaning of that story
and the studio wanted that out of there
they wanted it to be kind of left
ambiguous
which no originally he was he was a
replicant
and yeah replicants evidently can have
kids that's a weird [ __ ] man but
i think this might have been better and
it is
pretty faithful to the book i mean
some of the books is very vague so it
can be left open to interpretation
and like an ornithopter it does flap its
wings but it never really they never
really say much about it
and the way it's way orthopters are
presented in this movie is plausible to
the descriptions given in the book
which is a flying dragonfly a helicopter
that flies like a dragonfly with
dragonfly wings
one of the things i liked the best about
this movie was that uh connor island
just said villanova knows how to do
scope oh yeah big
um and another thing i liked about this
movie this movie really felt like
you were there i mean it was very
immersive
and everything looked like it would work
in the real world
everything just looked like grounded i
really loved all the shots of just like
everything being dusty and like the heat
waves and all this stuff it really like
made you fee and i like that it had this
sort of
it didn't look like that super sharp cgi
kind of stuff that a lot of fantasy
movies have you know what i'm talking
about right where everything is like
ultra hd it had this kind of like gauzy
it was dirty kind of soft yeah and i and
i think that really served it well
because it really made you feel like
this is a real place and this is a real
world and these are real people it
didn't have that ultra sharp fantasy
edge yeah well another thing is is they
gave you the it gave you the inter the
impression that you were watching a film
a film yeah you know what i mean it was
hd but not so ultra hd to like i said
everything was sharp it had a softer
softer tones and rounded stuff and it
just you know i mean just felt kind of
like a high class movie like a film you
know what i mean didn't have that video
game feel to it it was good yeah because
i kind of i feel like a lot of fantasy
movies have that nowadays where
everything has to be like super sharp
and yeah super colorful and stuff but
there's nothing wrong with that
depending on what you're doing the
application matters yeah but i think
when you're making something like dune
that's like you said almost kind of like
an old testament type thing i think it
looks better when it's kind of like
dusty and grungy and kind of soft
focused yeah i mean it gave it a lot
more gravitas part of it looked like
something out of ancient egypt in
ancient egypt and stuff you know with
the palm trees and the
the the [ __ ]
buildings like they're cut out of damn
sandstone and stuff and people out in
the desert kind of a middle eastern feel
you know man you know i've been to egypt
i lived there for six months you know in
the army and it does that's what running
around the desert kind of feels like you
know on a desert patrol that's what it
feels like
um although that was a very extreme you
know [ __ ] 600 mile an hour winds and
[ __ ]
you know not on this planet
but it was quite cool um
the sand worms looked amazing yeah they
looked pretty good i liked it uh
everything about it there was i could i
could not
nothing jumped out at me
that was a problem there was nothing
that i was shown in here that blew it
like oh no that didn't happen in the
dune universe or no that's that couldn't
exist in the dune universe there was
nothing that they showed could exist in
the dune universe there was nothing that
took you out of it neither it was
completely i mean i think from the time
that it started till the time that it
ended i was just kind of like
i was just completely like hypnotized by
it the whole time just watching just
completely immersed in it yeah and
what's funny is that they don't explain
anything but you can kind of follow
what's called you
if you didn't know anything about the
dune universe
you wouldn't notice to that certain i
don't think you would notice that things
weren't explained
like a bunch of [ __ ] happens never once
do they ever show any computer
technology but you don't really notice
it
and if you didn't know the dune universe
it probably wouldn't dawn on you that
they never show a computer
and it's because this is taking place
after something in this story called the
butlerian jihad which was a holy war
against
thinking machines
and men that controlled machines and
thinking machines so in other words it's
like it's like a jihad against a big
tech
and they
wrote down in their new religions
throughout the entire known universe and
all the royal houses
no more computers no more computers no
more ai
which that
gives a lot of damn
technological problems when you're space
faring
you have to use powers of the mind so
they're
making mentats and golems
angolas let's go which is [ __ ]
zombies
it's a bunch of weird technology that
they're using you know reviving dead
bodies wiping their minds re-educating
them to make them into human computers
called mentats
and every royal house had one they're
like a slave
i guess because you buy them because
they didn't have human rights because
they were the undead basically
and uh that's
that was not as threatening as a
computer and there's no computers in any
of the damn
machines
it's all nothing that can be
just interpreted as ai
so you have to have all these mental
powers and that's what this spice is all
about you have to go to dune to get
spice
spice gives you the damn psychic
premonitions you need in order to
navigate
in uh through space by when you're
making a wormhole so you can
travel without moving
so it kind of like interstellar [ __ ]
lsd
and you see and it also is kind of like
steroids it makes you stronger and it
makes you live longer so some of these
people in this
story are centuries old two three four
hundred years old but they don't look
old they
just keep you running so only real rich
people can afford spice
that's a great tail it's great too i
mean it's a great idea yeah yeah mango
says dune does take a lot from islamic
and nordic mythology not just the film
but the books too yeah all mythology
actually christian stuff a lot of
christian stuff in it um
western stuff you know the harkonnens
are basically
if you if you go back into dune lore the
harkonnens
are eastern europeans they're like a
mixture of the the finns and the
russians
um kaladan and
and house of tradies i guess is the is
the uk descendants of the uk probably
um
there's a bunch of other stuff that
exists over over time you know
x which is planet nine or
nine and then
that
civilization doesn't even live on planet
nine wherever they go they call it nine
one x or and they so they just pronounce
that x it's all kinds of weird [ __ ] in
this story you know
to me
for me uh you know better than the
hobbit and lord of the rings
it's similar to scope but better i think
it's just this is the first time it's
been done right on film or in video
and you know there's a lot of potential
here
if you do this right
you could replace star wars easily and
lord of the rings if you get
doomed right i mean i was just going to
say that it just goes to show
that
if you know what you're doing from a
filmmaking standpoint you can take
something as epic and complicated as
dune
and put it into a movie that even if you
haven't read the book i mean it's hard
for me to say but
i kind of feel like even if you haven't
read the book i don't think you'd find
it all that hard to follow yeah not
really as long as you're kind of paying
attention to what's going on but you
know i'd say that about every movie you
can't just like let it wash over you and
expect to know what's going on but if
you pay attention
um
pretty much everything is in there and
it doesn't need a lot of exposition it
doesn't need a lot of because everything
is kind of shown and you just kind of
make inferences from that yeah you know
what i'm saying so i so i think that
you know i'm comparing it and
contrasting it like i said to david
lynch's one where
even though like i said i hate to call
it that but
you know where everything had to be
exposition which i don't think he even
wanted i think the studios were just
like well no one's gonna know what the
[ __ ] is going on because there's just
like too much stuff and it's too
complicated so we have to put this
narrative like explaining all this stuff
but this movie shows you don't need that
all that literally all that it had it
had i think for a second like it said
what year it was like 10 000 whatever
and then 100 191 yeah and then like
whatever and then whenever it goes to
another
world like you know when it goes to like
getting prime and stuff like that it put
it on there but that's it that's like
the only thing that it had and other
than that it just let the audience you
know
pay attention and see what was going on
and i did not find it hard to follow it
out yeah it said it said ten thousand
one ninety one but it's not that's not a
d if you actually go through dune lore
that's about twenty 000 years from right
now because they they changed the
calendar several times
um but 10 000 191 that's that was the
the year it's quite cool you know and i
do like another thing that i really
liked about dune and i like that
they continued with this theme
with the new movies
the importance of religion to mankind
and things like mankind because in in
this tale
humanity is old enough and now has the
technology enough to through genetic
engineering to be kind of like other
than humans there's transhumanism going
on
um
and they all kind of have their own
religions some of them are based on
religions we would know
some of it is a merger between islam and
christianity emerge into one mixed with
things that happened in the butlerian
jihad which haven't happened yet
so it's kind of like you took more kind
of like merging
christianity with islam and then putting
a mormon spin on it or something like
that you know that that is going on
mixed with witches
like the the benny jesuit and then you
have i guess what are non-theistic
religions going on between the mentats
they kind of have their own religions
but they're not about god they're more
about illogic logic and mental acuity
and
then the show in this one they'll show
that even the solder car which were
sadder car were from salacious secundus
and it was a prison planet and they were
they would send prisoners there that
would the environment would kill them
but then the strongest of them were
trained as soldiers and then they fought
each other until only the very tops of
top quality would survive and those
would be
freed kinda as mercenaries of the
emperor
and they showed them worshiping their
religion and human sacrifice going on it
looked like human sacrifice to me when
that wasn't that was going on they had
them upside down were cutting their
throats and draining blood out of them
and they had like their version of a
damn pope and
and i like that they continued with that
because that's close real if you look at
human history that one of the driving
force between all humanity is some kind
of a religion be it
deistic
or or non-theistic you know in other
words it's either
some kind of a
like buddhism you know it doesn't not
really so much about a god and then
there's philosophies and fake science
like scientology and
people believe in something that's what
binds them together especially in large
groups and that's how you motivate them
you have to have they have to have some
kind of philosophy or religion to drive
them
and this
they got in this movie man because i
think it's very human element humans are
like that
and um it did get into the trans-human
element
baron conan had some kind of a pet
it looks like a giant black widow spider
until you look real close to that and
it's a human that's been modified to
look like a spider with little hands it
was creepy
yeah and they it was cool because they
just kind of showed it for a minute they
didn't really comment on it all that
much yeah they fed it and it was eaten
out of a bowl it's the size of a person
but it's got eight arms
didn't have any legs just arms and it
was walking on its hands
and that benny jesuit goes get out of
here
get out and he goes oh it doesn't
understand your language and then it
left she used the voice on it left
because see it understands
like she didn't want that thing around
i heard that they're making i don't know
if they've done it yet but um i heard
they're making a prequel series which is
all about the bennet jezeret which is
called i think it's just called dune the
sisterhood i think they're doing that
for hbo max
so they are making uh so they are doing
like an extended universe stuff which is
kind of like par for the course nowadays
a lot of potential but man it's got it's
got to pass the test
it has to stay within
frank hubert's [ __ ] concept of you
know what i mean and there's some also
some really good fanfic
you know some books came out
in recent years that evidently i've
never read them but according to like
the dune fans they love it you know the
same thing happen with star trek anybody
who loves star trek and can write can
write a good star trek story yeah
they're doing that too but it has to fit
within that motif
and um but now the transhuman thing that
was [ __ ] great because they were
making people look like anything that
they wanted and
kind of a brutal
monarchies and stuff fighting each other
and
yeah
i mean i think he did a great job this
was i mean i was expecting it to be good
because like i said i loved blade runner
2049 and i loved arrival so i was like
well you know and after hearing what a
big fan he was of dune as a you know as
a book and being like you know i've
always wanted to do this and he was
really excited because they've been
bouncing the rights for this around
since like [ __ ] 1996 right and like i
said i hate to [ __ ] on like david
lynch's one because there are a lot of
things i like about david lynch's
adaptation it was just i think that he
was given an impossible task
i mean visually that looks spectacular
you know and it has all the elements
there it's just like like you said it
just got like chopped up the studio
didn't really trust him to do what he
wanted to do they couldn't make it as
long as they wanted it was all this
other kind of stuff i mean when
alejandra jodorowsky was gonna make it
he was gonna make the [ __ ] like 14 hours
long you know yeah so
and it's like you do kind of need
more than one movie like this game and
this movie is it being two hours i think
it's two hours and 35 minutes right and
then they're gonna do the second part
the second part has been greenlit um but
it's going to be like two years before
it's out i think it's coming out october
2023 is when it's supposed to come out
so it has actually been greenlit and
this
i was read i just looked on the
wikipedia page and they said as of two
days ago it's almost made twice its
budget back okay which is good so it's
because to make to break even it would
have to make 300 million and i think
it's made 225 at this point so um and
they've already got they're already
gonna do a part two like that's already
been
greenlit at the pace that the movie is
going i think you could tell this into
in
in one more movie i don't think it needs
three but they'll probably will go for
three i'm trying to bet
yeah i don't know i mean two would do it
i mean this pretty much encompassed more
or less like the first half of the book
um so
i don't know i don't know we'll see
there's a bunch of stuff that could
happen after like in the in the dune
messiah period too
um or you could just make a totally
original
prequels you know you could do something
happening happening in the butler in
jihad you could do all kinds of stuff
with it there's a lot of potential
but um
khan and uh i think it was louis were
saying that star wars was kind of a rip
off of dune uh i think star wars
according to luke
to lucas star wars is more a ripoff of
flash gordon
yeah he was more into like the old
serials like from the early 20th century
early days of film yeah but um khan says
this he said that this is an opportunity
to have something kind of like star wars
and still keep it kind of r-rated since
yeah that that is true yeah because this
is more like and and i will say i mean
dune is obviously more star wars is kind
of like for everybody it's kind of like
you know crowd pleasing everybody can
get into it even if they're not into
sci-fi i you know i would argue that to
be into dune you kind of have to be into
sci-fi
um because it's kind of more i just i
don't know if it's necessarily it's not
hard sci-fi but
i don't know it's just kind of it's it's
it's more of like a complicated more of
an adult type story and it's kind of
harder to
get into
first for general audiences i guess
the interesting thing about dune is that
in the dune universe
mankind has in some cases has kind of
evolved through natural and unnatural
means evolved into other species or
slightly different species
but they haven't seen any
extraterrestrials there's no aliens they
haven't found any they found some ruins
but they don't know
they don't they didn't when they found
them they didn't know if they were some
kind of ancient human habitat
that was forgotten or if they were
extraterrest there wasn't any proof but
they haven't found any aliens which
that's really unique
in science fiction science fiction
usually has aliens in it well yeah
that's kind of the fun of doing science
fiction it's like we want to yeah not
dude they found alien
life
but not
uh like plants and [ __ ]
in animals like the worms you know but
uh
no alien
intelligence beings or technology
yeah because everything that's on all
the planets there's animals and stuff
but they would look like animals that
would have evolved on those planets you
know what i mean yeah no alien
civilizations
word 789 is uh asking
why um let me see where was that why did
the emperor give house of tradies uh a
raucous just to end up attacking them
anyway well that was the plan
that i mean and i'm pretty sure they
said that in the movie uh later on they
discovered they're like oh the emperor
basically set us up because he knew that
by installing them on a rackus that the
other guys would
yeah what what
what um
they said
pretty much just right at the top
is that the harkonnens got so rich that
they were starting to threaten the
emperor
so he took the chome
agreement which is the with the with the
spicing guild they took that away from
the harkonnens
all right and gave it to the atreides
they told the harkonnens that they did
it because they wanted them to
annihilate the atreides okay because the
the the atreides were getting too
powerful too popular in the in the lans
rod in other words they were becoming
politically powerful and they were
becoming a threat
the emperor
his true motive what he said was is he
was trying to weaken and destroy both
the harkonnens and the atreides because
they were both a threat to him yeah
because the harkonnens had to spend all
that money
to re-evade to re-invade into uh
into uh doom and the baron even says
that at one point when he's coming out
of the tub like after being healed gotta
recoup all that loss yeah he's like how
much money i spent like dude like on the
battle you know right now
what the emperor told him is it was kind
of like a contract job i want you to
kill the atreides for me
you know what i mean
but
baron harkonnen knew
that the the true
the true reason why the emperor did it
was to weaken
hal sarkonin and get rid of the atreides
because house harkonnen
is planning to not only get rid of the
atreides because they didn't like the
atreides they had a grudge that went
back generations house arcana was also
going to overthrow house carino who was
the emperor
so
now that now vladimir harcon
he was a baron he was part of the lonz
rod which the lance rod was kind of like
their version of like the council of all
the all all the
um
uh noble houses you know it's kind of
like their version of the senate he had
to respect all these institutions like
the bene jesuit the chum contracts the
spicing guilds and the throne of the
imperium
he had to respect that so he couldn't
openly attack the emperor but he was
going to
because they had been
the house arkhonen its military and its
royal family you
had a long tradition
of
inter competition and assassination
and trickery to gain power that is that
was the
approved means of gaining authority that
was that was gaining authority by
natural means
so um
by extension
as far as harkona would consider that if
you could murder the emperor and take
his place that was that's your job yeah
that's a gold
that that would mean that you're better
than that person
so it's your right to take what you can
get
and um
house kaladan and the and the atreides
weren't like that they they had a blood
feud that went way back and
you know so that fight was going to
happen you know i guess you could say
atreides were kind of the generic good
guys and the harkonnens were the generic
bad guys they're just two different
views on how [ __ ] was supposed to be
done you know
yeah yeah
nothing i was just oh yeah yeah but no
they it was all the plot it's court
intrigue that's why
it's why the emperor did it try to get
rid of tradies and the [ __ ]
harkonnens
yeah it was like kind of essentially
kind of setting them against each other
because he knew that that's what was
going to happen yeah and then all while
kind of also
maintaining plausible deniability a
little bit like keeping his keeping his
hands out of it dude
it was trap yeah duke lido knew it was
trap remember paul's like why are we
doing it you know he says well i have to
accept
you have to accept the deal because
that's you know that's the duty of a
duke so it's not like you could tell the
emperor to [ __ ] off no i don't i don't
want yeah it was all about like
everything is bound up in like honor and
tradition and stuff like that so it's
like if they ask you to do it you kind
of have to do it you don't really have
much of a choice yeah i mean early on
you know when lido is trying to make
some money to defend himself when he's
there and the [ __ ] equipment's all
been sabotaged and [ __ ] you know what
i mean and the emperor's plotting
against him and
it was it was a plot to get rid of the
tradies from the very beginning and they
knew it
they did it yeah they did kind of knew
but they were kind of like had them you
know they were kind of by the short and
curlies you know it's like they're not
they didn't really have a lot of choices
there's no choice they had to go they
didn't really have a lot of choice in
that yeah you know so it's it's kind of
that but yeah it's it's good because
like i said i've
you know i i kind of i know the outline
of the story because i read the book but
it was a long time ago so i kind of
remember a lot of the stuff from it but
all of the interest intricacies and
stuff i probably like forgot about but i
honestly did not have any problem at all
like following the movie um even though
it doesn't have like a bunch of
exposition dumps or anything like that i
thought it was like a question
uh somebody word 789 okay yeah see
that's a sign you didn't watch the first
movie because the old david lynch
version in act one the first thing they
tell you is that [ __ ] the guild is
going to investigate the damn emperor
because they have foreseen using their
mental powers that the emperor was
plotting against [ __ ] house of
tradies and gonna use that that was
another thing too and i do it and i
think they brought this up at some point
too is that i think it was when they
were going to um dump paul and his mom
into the desert yeah and they were like
somebody was like why don't you just
like cut their throats and they're like
well because they can't because there's
like a lot of uh [ __ ] that can
like read people's minds yeah and and
they got things called truth sayers
it's a benny jesuit which that if she
gets around you she can [ __ ] use
suggestion and power the mind to get you
to tell the truth yeah and you see they
had
baron uh baron harcone and
the ben and jesuit told baron harkonnen
that you look you can't kill jessica or
paul because they're part of the benny
jesuit you have to let them they're
under their protection yeah and you'll
be threatened yeah you have they have to
go into exile and heart conan says oh
yeah i would never go against the benny
jesuit they'll you know i won't have
anything to do with their deaths so he
made sure that the desert would kill him
yeah that was it wasn't us yeah it
wasn't enough desert did it so that was
the plausible deniability
because they could get in there and read
your mind or they can make you say the
truth
and uh the in this version they knew
about the voice which is the power of
suggestion you know it's kind of like a
jedi mind trick but they just used it
through techniques using the voice you
know how to convince somebody using
psychic powers
the harkonnens that were taking them out
to dump them off into the desert so they
die out in the desert one of them was
death
which get made him resistant
to their powers of suggestion it didn't
work though you just got to see how that
goes down and it was funny the way the
guy opened his mouth and started talking
that harkonnen soldier that i have a
cousin who's deaf that's the way a deaf
person sounds the [ __ ] i did was
deaf i could tell
well i would hope i mean i kind of feel
like nowadays they should probably get
someone that actually has is hearing
impaired to play a part of somebody
that's hearing impaired yeah
you know it's not like there's not a
huge pool of actors of talented actors
with disabilities that yeah you would
think well hold on you got a heart conan
special forces guy who's deaf well
deafness in that world would have been a
special ability because it made you
resistant
to benny jesus technology so you would
be like a valuable asset
and they were doing [ __ ] like that
mental powers and
yeah it's like that in the book you know
[ __ ] yeah that'd be kind of cool
being deaf would be an advantage in
certain circumstances so you'd want some
soldiers that were like that
yeah because they would be uh immune to
certain
types of attacks well imagine if you're
imagine if you're fighting a whole bunch
of damn medusas and if you saw them
you'd turn to stone well that wouldn't
affect you yeah
that's how you do it
i mean perseus did look at her in the
mirror
the reflection
that'd be the end of
that they feel like
i can't see the [ __ ] well you could
probably if you had several blind dudes
you could train them to fight one
another yeah they could use like echo
locations
situation yeah yeah they could get good
at it because i have heard that people
that were that have been blind their
whole life can do like some kind of
echolocation just watch the [ __ ]
series zatuiji yeah that's what you're
blind swordsman yeah yeah
it doesn't matter if it's dark or not so
you attack during the darkness when
other people can't see it doesn't matter
to you
yeah yeah so you have an advantage the
problem is the blind person doesn't know
when it's dark you need to be does it
dark yeah it's dark okay
yeah true yeah but uh but yeah so i mean
basically i was i was not disappointed
at all i thought this was like i knew it
was going to be epic and amazing and all
that other kind of stuff but yeah i
think i mean i think they did he did a
really really good job gonna say i just
i'd like to see it again it's beautiful
to look at the sound design
is incredible the score is incredible um
just everything about it it's just like
i said it just like really sucked me in
and i was just kind of like i was
sitting there with my little box of m ms
just like watching the [ __ ] and it was i
noticed there wasn't a [ __ ] ton of
people in the theater it wasn't we were
in the dolby one so it was like the big
one with the comfy seats
um and we went at like four o'clock in
the afternoon or 4 30. it's like it
wasn't packed but there was
you know a good amount of people in
there and i'm pretty sure through that
whole two and a half hour movie it was
definitely silent i didn't hear a single
person cough or rattle anything or talk
or nothing 789 says yeah they caught
them all while they were asleep and
attacked it yeah you're missing a lot of
you had to read the book and you had to
pay attention
the um the traitor that they had what
was his name uh uh
the the doctor doctor um oh [ __ ] i just
i thought of it and then it just went
flitting right in true if he paid
attention he drugged the entire
royal family yeah and then he he
assassinated their bodyguards using
those
darts this poison and then he lowered
the shield wall
and yeah they said they had us came in
yeah
and that that
that's how the attack initiated now um
just the royal family was asleep because
they had been they had been drugged yeah
he drugged him and um
paul was drugs too
and uh then they uh
uh the soldiers fought
out there but they got annihilated by
those [ __ ] um
um it was a mixture of harkonnen troops
and then the cider car came in there
they kind of had like their version of
paratroopers they'd come down on any
gravity
things and land down behind them
um
i think another thing that confuses
people that in dune there's no guns
guns don't work in dune because they all
have those shields
and those personal shields anything fast
moving
gets stopped by those shields
so the only way to get through those
shields is with things like blades but
you have to go slow
do it once it hits you got to like force
it slowly your fight against it and
slashes will work
and then they had another kind of like a
dart gun
that would hit and it once it hit the
shield would start spinning and slow
down
and try to force its way through that
electromagnetic shield then go in it was
poisonous
um
so it was a lot of hand-to-hand stuff
and and darts and and [ __ ]
now they did have some rays like
remember when the ornithopter was
running and the damn ray comes down and
it's
trying to catch up with it and it's
[ __ ] annihilating the damn yeah it
was like laser tag things yeah
in dune
that ray gun could not hit anything with
a shield if it hit that shield it would
destroy not only that
all of that uh not only destroy the
enemy would destroy you because the
energy from that shield would go suck up
be sucked up inside that ring go into
your weapon and explode like a bomb
so you had to be careful what you shot
with whether with any of these ray guns
or a laser or whatever because uh
it would kill you
so they were shooting at that
ornithopter because it wasn't it
evidently wasn't shielded
anything shielded to [ __ ] blow you up
and um
you had to be careful with them so no
ray guns no guns
yeah which like i said i think that kind
of makes more things more like exciting
and yeah you got to do more like
hand-to-hand combat well you could have
you could have machine guns and [ __ ]
just that they just bounce off those
guys yeah you know so it's like not much
it wasn't working right yeah
yeah so everything and i liked it
because everything it was almost kind of
like watching an old samurai movie
everything has to be done like with some
like poison and yeah you know [ __ ] like
sneaky [ __ ] yeah
they had guided missiles they had bombs
they had a nuclear warheads they had all
that but nuclear weaponry was bad
and
they were there were still some laying
around
uh but they were kind of like
the the lonzo and the emperor had
decided you weren't supposed to have
those so to have them was like
contraband and if you used them you had
to do it where the emperor knew and
would look the other way yeah if you
used those and you didn't get approval
by the emperor you were [ __ ] because
they kill you
they wipe out your whole family
so um
in in the original doom book they use
and in this story eventually they will
use nuclear weapons
but the emperor is kind of like on the
sly allowed them to do it
actually i think it already happened
well that attack they did actually
yeah yeah they were used to small
nuclear weapons to [ __ ] up the shield
wall i believe
yeah that was like a pretty epic scene
too yeah i was gonna say too i almost
forgot to say this uh nice to see javier
bardem in this he wasn't in a lot he's
probably going to be more in it in the
second one but uh yeah it's always cold
sadly i love that guy so it's always
like cool to see him it's just you know
just everybody that was cast in this was
great and the and the woman that played
uh paula trady's mom she's uh
you know lady jessica that was she was
just in uh dr sleep
wasn't she she was uh rose the hat
because remember i told you that
afterward and you were like oh yeah the
whole movie i was wondering where have i
seen that woman before yeah she was in
doctor sleep but uh yeah so actually i'm
kind of now we have to wait two years to
see the second part yeah but now they're
talking about the difference between the
aesthetics of this one and the original
lynch one i like the aesthetics in both
yeah they're it's a totally different
thing but yeah now there's a really good
game i have a uh it's called a dune
emperor it's an old game kind of like
command and i think it's called command
and cocker it's like that i have a
[ __ ] old computer that can that i use
just for that game
every now and then i'll set that [ __ ]
pc up and running
i can't get it to run anything else it's
old yeah it's really old it's from late
90s yeah yeah it's got a really good
soundtrack and
uh well it's got clips from the david
lynch movie like or it's like cut scenes
cut scenes it's it's in that same motif
yeah it's not from the movie though it's
a different story yeah well i mean they
have some of the same actors like oh
yeah kind of michael doran's in it yeah
he plays
duke lido and they have the harkonnens
in it and they have the house ordos and
[ __ ] and
you just
have to mine spice and [ __ ] build
[ __ ] and [ __ ] make armies and fight
each other using carryalls and it's got
all that but uh there's supposed to be a
way where you can get that to work in a
modern computer but i'm not that
computer savvy
to uh there's a program i think that you
can download into a modern computer to
run those old video games yeah i'm sure
you can i mean you can do everything
nowadays
but uh yeah so it's just funny that you
have that one old computer
that's the only thing that does it
that's the only thing it does is play
dunamis i was going to dismantle that pc
and put it in a video arcade cabinet and
jenny was going to make the graph the
graphics for the cabinet
the thing is about that game you have to
have a mouse yeah without a mouse that
game is not fun so you can't run it with
a trackball or a joystick just kind of
like missile command
you can't play a missile command without
a trackball if it doesn't have trackball
[ __ ] it you gotta have a trackball yeah
well that dune game without a mouse it's
you know so you have to somehow re in a
clean way incorporate a mouse into a
arcade cabinet which i'm not really sure
how you would do that have a pad there i
got that mouse on a wire
i guess that would work yeah but yeah
and you have to have access to your
keyboard so you have to have a keyboard
sitting there too
because there's so it's like you know
what just let's just might as well leave
it on the camera
kiosk on the top you could just put the
monitor inside of like a little
miniature cabinet that's what it is yeah
that's what it is yeah you put the
monitor inside a miniature cabinet it
would be a small cabinet yeah you know
we'll have to do not a full-size cabinet
yeah sometimes he'd sit there for hours
and play that game and it's just like
and the the little guys every time you
command your little dudes to do
something
yeah they're just so they always like
say something
yeah so as soon as you try to like sign
it drives a non-player [ __ ] crazy
yeah
you can stop all the voices but i i
actually got so used to hearing them say
acknowledged
moving out sir and [ __ ] like that
yeah and the heart conan's [ __ ] stay
back
you know getting ready to kill
[Laughter]
they're [ __ ] overloading the reactors
on the damn devastators devastation time
boom you're coming with me
when it blows up and [ __ ] yeah
it looks like a fun game but yeah so if
you're just listening to somebody else
play it it's just like a constant stream
of little army guys being like
yes sir moving out sir kind of stuff
like that one thing i don't like about
it is that like in the ai and the ai is
not that good it'd be better if you had
two people through two different
computers which you can link to them
together to fight each other on the same
map that would be a lot more challenging
yeah because you can play i mean you can
play any of the houses right yeah and
then uh you know so yeah you play any
house
and then there's a bunch of sub houses
that you can get access to like
house ex
[ __ ]
the the framing [ __ ] and you got to
build little harvesters yeah
factories harvesters wind traps would
make power and [ __ ] you need uh
no just just all kinds of stuff you know
research
facilities um to get better weapons
[ __ ] airstrips and [ __ ]
kind of reminds me of a really old game
also probably from the 90s which i think
was called populous
yes where you could you know what i'm
saying where you could have you could
pick what kind of terrain you wanted
yeah and then you had to like build a
civilization on it you had to like build
farms and little buildings and [ __ ] like
that but you guys can go on youtube and
go a [ __ ] um dune
emperor
soundtrack and go and they got the
soundtrack to all the houses and the
different uh you know and when you're
playing that game
you hear the music you know and
it's pretty cool anything that's [ __ ]
harkonnen related if you're playing
harkonnen all you hear is straight power
metal through the whole [ __ ] thing
because of course yes
and [ __ ] you know the titles of the
songs are [ __ ] badass you know what i
mean like [ __ ] just weird [ __ ] like
death before dishonor and [ __ ] you
know no mercy for the week or whatever
that kind of [ __ ] you know crush your
enemies [ __ ] like that
and then like uh house orders and
[ __ ] house of tradies you all have
different theme music and you know
hordos is kind of like you know mellow
and brave and [ __ ] trumpets and [ __ ]
you know
ordos is [ __ ] they're a bunch of
[ __ ] basically they're basically a
big old [ __ ] merchant cartel their
shit's all [ __ ]
kind of like techno techno industrial
that's weird because looking
the
the one that's in charge of them is a
group hive mind between like five people
who've been merged together
their brains have been merged together
and they speak through a
agola
in other words a [ __ ]
zombie
and when it talks it's the voices of
like five people coming out of it but
then it goes to a translator that's
mechanical it's real [ __ ] creepy
and what's it called the
not the uh
the the something or other tricks the
[ __ ]
it's basically the the ceo that runs the
corporation it's [ __ ] creepy and it's
telling you to do things giving you your
mission mission or your orders for your
mission
which a lot of the shit's illegal you
know like use poison gas inside the high
liner before we arrive
you know don't let the good idea yeah
don't let that because yeah because the
same guild highliner is taking the
both sides of the [ __ ] war
two
too [ __ ] doomed to fight each other
and you know you're like and you're not
allowed to attack each other inside the
highliner but
if you play one of the bad guys they're
like oh by the way
[ __ ] the guild and the lance well that's
why we're gonna kill him inside the
highlighter on the way there because
they do like wait a minute before we get
there though yeah yeah yeah that's kind
of the whole definition of it right yeah
breaking rules yeah yeah breaking the
law
yeah yeah uh yeah so basically dune was
awesome yes and i can't wait until the
second part
um
this weekend oh also this weekend
uh one night in soho and antlers both
start this weekend i'm pretty sure
so
yay so we'll have some like uh movies
we'll have to talk about they're still
waiting on the interview with a vampire
review
i thought we did that didn't we we did
an interview with the vampire a long
time well it wasn't a long time ago it
was maybe like a year or two ago i
remember the name that thing was called
the executrix okay the executrix was
[ __ ]
what was the one that was [ __ ]
telling you to do all that [ __ ]
and if you'd fail they would remove your
head and keep it alive
word 789 said what happened to tv and
technology in the world of dune
yeah tom already explained that but
basically what it is is that computers
this is like way in the future and
computers are outlawed because or
anything like that is outlawed because
technical because they kind of felt like
technology caused
it was called the butlerian jihad yeah
like all this destruction and what it
was is uh a
basically it was a situation kind of
like big tech had happened
um they created some ai robots or ai
compute super computers and
people started to manipulate ai and
robots to enslave mankind yes so like a
skynet type situation right so right but
men were behind it yeah uh and then some
of the ai was even better than men
so they were big they were almost kind
of like partners in it
so there was
so some of these computers were you know
surpassed human intellect
and they started to take over
uh if if you look at
go to [ __ ] dune
uh epilogue and it'll be from the
television
edition of that and there's like a
little animated featurette that explains
why
dune ended why the dune universe went
the way that it went
um
ai almost took over it made mankind
basically weak slaves and
it
it became like a like a high-tech nanny
state you weren't allowed to do anything
they constantly kept you imprisoned for
your own safety
people started to atrophy human
abilities started to atrophy people got
fat stupid and weak
um a revolt
happened
and uh they were eventually overthrown
but it was it actually took
in the little featurette they make it
seem like it happened on one planet it
happened in a whole system of planets
there's a bunch of them
a bunch of planets were involved in it
and they eventually
got rid of ai and they
made a new religion this took every this
is over a period of like a thousand
years i believe
they basically re-wrote holy books and
made new laws inside the lonze rod to
ban
any machine that was made in the image
of the mind of man so no ai no
no computers
so everything was mechanical
or analog yeah you could still have
analog or mechanical things you just
couldn't have any kind of like
artificial intelligence no artificial
intelligence
yeah so
and then they opened up new schools
the spice the spacing guilds and the
benny jesuit and all that and they were
using and the mentats they used
human ability and drugs to expand human
ability and genetic engineering and
stuff
some people weren't totally human at
when the you know it's in some ways like
for instance
there's one planet
that because of its religion
they tried to get away from temptation
and one of the temptations was sex
so they eliminated basically sex
they did this by getting rid of women
they were only men
what served as a woman was just a torso
that was genetically engineered that had
a womb in it and they artificially
inseminated those
and men came out of it
that's some spooky [ __ ] it's like a
whole mgtow planet like a big top planet
so and they were kind of uh and then the
me and so that was kind of a weird
[ __ ] thing women were totally banned
that's weird
but um
i don't think there's any full stories
written about it in the dune universe i
think it's just mentioned
it's just that planet was mentioned
yeah it's just kind of like background
yeah
so you're not dealing with the same kind
of [ __ ] world as like say star wars
huh weirder
yeah
but like i said a lot a lot more
interesting a lot more unique i guess
yeah in that regard
all right you done yeah
yeah i got a whole i got some other
videos i gotta do and tonight we're
going back to the theater because
tonight is rifftrax live
they're doing the halloween special
tonight i think they're doing amityville
four
so we haven't been to one of those in a
while so i'm kind of excited i think
tonight at eight we're gonna go see
riptrax live
but uh yeah so i guess tomorrow's
wednesday
so we're gonna be doing the regular show
tomorrow evening at 5 00 p.m and since
it's sort of the pre-halloween show and
uh the two i'm we're gonna do like two
um
two topics because they were the ones
that were the top of the poll but there
are guys it's like two kind of fun
paranormal type [ __ ] so it should be
entertaining uh but yeah we'll see you
guys again tomorrow and thanks for
dropping bye